Eureka moments are few and far between
in the world of science. When they do
happen, however, they can turn an
entire field on its head. A compelling
example is the discovery of RNA
interference, or RNAi. Often
revolutionary discoveries come from
scientists following an unusual
observation during their studies. For
doctors Andrew Fire and Craig Mello,
that came when they saw a mutant strain
of C. elegans, a type of worm commonly
used as an animal model, display an
unusual twitching behavior. They had
been studying how gene expression is
controlled, but to understand their
surprising observation, we first have
to understand this critical process by
which DNA a is turned into proteins.
First DNA, which is made up of two
complementary strands, is unzipped and
a complex of proteins turns one of
these strands into a single strand of
RNA known as messenger RNA, or mRNA.
This mRNA is then read by a different
complex of proteins, resulting in the
assembly of a functional protein. So
doctors Fire and Mello decided to see
if introducing various forms of RNA
sequences that matched an RNA
responsible for a worm muscle protein
would block production of that protein
and result in the twitching behavior.
First, they introduced single-stranded
RNA, or ssRNA,
that was complementary to the target
RNA, thinking that this would block the
cell's ability to read the RNA.
But to their surprise, the worms were
completely normal. Then they tried
pairing the ssRNA with a partner strand
to create double-stranded RNA and
injected this double-stranded RNA into
the worms, as opposed to
single-stranded RNA. To their surprise,
the double stranded RNA caused the
worms to twitch, signaling that the
protein had been turned off or silenced.
This unexpected observation set off a
chain of experiments which ultimately
revealed that double-stranded RNA is a
signal for cells to initiate a series
of molecular events that leads to the
destruction of a matched RNA sequence.
Doing so prevents production of the
protein encoded by the RNA. This entire
process is known as RNA interference,
or RNAi. Doctors Fire and Mello
published their initial findings in
1998 and won the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or Medicine in 2006. But why
was this discovery so important?
In the years that followed Dr. Fire and
Dr. Mello's initial findings,
scientists began to understand that
RNAi is a process that naturally
evolved in many organisms for a variety
of functions. For example, cells use it
as a defense mechanism against viruses.
When viruses cause infection, they
inject their genetic material into
cells. Many viruses have genomes made
up of double-stranded RNA, which
activates the cell's RNAi machinery to
quickly degrade the viral RNA and
prevent the spread of infection. RNAi
is also an elegant form of genetic
regulation. MicroRNAs are small RNA
fragments encoded throughout the genome
of many organisms, and they can bind to
certain RNA molecules creating
double-stranded RNA, which ultimately
blocks protein production. MicroRNAs
play critical roles in numerous
cellular functions, such as cell growth
and differentiation, and have been
implicated in various diseases such as
cancer.
Today RNAi is also used as a strategy
to remove the function of a specific
gene and examine how that impacts the
cell. For example, scientists can use
small interfering RNAs, or siRNAs, a
type of RNAi technology, to pair with
and degrade a natural RNA in the cell.
Doing so allows researchers to identify
the role of a specific protein by
studying the cellular outcomes in its
absence.
RNAi also has found its way into
medicine. In 2018, patisiran, an siRNA
molecule, was approved for a disease of
the nervous system caused by hereditary
transthyretin-mediated amyloidosis
(hATTR).
This disease is characterized by the
abnormal build up of a protein called
transthyretin in the nervous system,
which can impact movement, heart rate
and digestion.
Patisiran directly targets the RNA
responsible for making transthyretin,
thereby limiting accumulation of the
disease-causing protein. Patients who
received patisiran in a clinical trial
had significantly improved muscle
strength and movement, compared to
people receiving a placebo.
This landmark approval ushered in an
entirely new class of medicines for
patients who had few options beforehand.
Looking back, it's pretty incredible
that an entirely new class of medicines
all started with some twitching worms.
But this is actually very typical of
how science works. Breakthrough
discoveries begin with curious
scientists following unusual
observations. Albert Einstein summed it
up best by saying, "I have no special
talents, I am only passionately
curious."